in today's challenge episode we're going
to play with the world's most uneven
racket see how many papers we can slice
with a ping pong ball and more let's get
into it you have two touches first with
a racket second with the head
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this is gonna be a sweaty game
[Music]
suicide shot
[Music]
what was that though
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
okay oh good match good match I'm
usually a bit drier than this so
challenge One Beat vehicle oh my God I
can't see anything
no no this is this is unbelievably
difficult
it's like slow motion good matching
thanks ah no chance Emily I promise it
can't be that difficult whoa
[Music]
like you really can't see okay now I'm
gonna smash it through
[Music]
I got it like I got one I got one try
try to even score one point I'll try to
get one hit
new tactic
oh you hit it you hit it one point
[Music]
that challenge was too difficult next up
the bouncing challenge catch the ball
yeah we've done this before show us how
it's done
Nick you look smart like a scientist not
science
you look like a beginner
well you come and try yeah I will I will
so that was disappointing there's zero
chance you just can't see it so the red
cup there is the Target and the one who
gets it with the least prize wins
are they going too much over it's
definitely too low
[Music]
five
that was really difficult
how did you go too low hey that was
close whoa
oh that was close that was really close
twenty oh again so close
in the beginning but then I lost the
touch I think the goggles are tested
these were impossible robots so the goal
is clear get it stick between
Otto's fingers
starting to feel a little tingle in the
arm
oh my God you were quite accurate but
not accurate enough
no this is very difficult
I've just been staring at that hole
between up those fingers so long I can't
see anything else
no
oh
very good
so X jump between every shot have you
ever done an X jump before
[Music]
so ridiculous
[Music]
this must be the stupidest thing we've
ever done but you know what isn't stupid
building the world's biggest chocolate
racket once we hit five million
subscribers help us out and hit
subscribe
[Music]
looks like a cheerleader
[Music]
yes maybe that's enough yeah no more the
next challenge is to glue as many table
tennis balls as possible to cover the
racket instead of rubbers the ball
rubber that looks so funny we have a new
racket there are 14 balls on each side
oh wow
yes too
it actually is it's
quite fast
oh it was first time luck how many
bouncers can you get
it's really it can't be that difficult
one two three four five yeah like this
is really that difficult
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
that's a good record okay so this is so
hard that we'll ask some people from the
other side to try it we have Sam from
The Bouncing contest if you get 10
bosses you get 100 euros
three four five six seven eight oh okay
one two three four five
too hard for me give this video gets 100
000 likes we'll make this into a public
challenge two three four five six okay
the challenge is to get one bounce more
after every single shot oh we can do
like 20. all right let's go
one one two three
one two three four five no that's too
fast
this is a really hard three four five
six one two three four five
I'm pretty sure six is the current world
record of doing this with a racket
yes
one two three one two three four one two
three four five one two three four five
six one two three four five six seven
one two three
what we got seven seven nice yes we're
gonna see how many pieces of paper we
can slice with a ping pong ball
[Laughter]
I think we should get five I mean it's
not the thickest paper it's like this
thin rice paper so don't want to miss
this shot
[Laughter]
we can do 20. let's just trip like full
of paper now yeah call me later do we
have now we have one two three 21 22
layers if I can get the shot straight
then we should get all of them all of
them yes I guess these 14 layers I've
got everybody watching me it's lots of
pressure
foreign
[Applause]
and continue from here
one two three four five six seven seven
again seven was the golden number
another golden number is five million
that we are trying to reach so please
help us out and hit subscribe until next
time